au bord du lac brome en montérégie le
biologiste jean françois des roches est
inquiet le résultat de ces recherches
est clair le lac est envahie par les
crever sa tache rouge plein d'écrevisses
tâche mais sa tache rouge c'est
uniquement des écrivains s'attacheront
les crever sa tache rouge est une espèce
exotique envahissante qui provient des
états unis selon le ministère des forêts
de la faune et des parcs
son intrusion au québec est préoccupante
plus forte que les écrevisses indigènes
et la rive rapidement à les éliminer
d'un territoire côté biodiversité c'est
vraiment sur le problème afin que le
désastre on peut au potentiel majeur
c'est vraiment la perte de la diversité
des espèces
l'écrevisse 7h rouge a sans doute été
introduite au lac brome par des pêcheurs
qui s'en servait comme appât vivant
maintenant la principale inquiétude est
de voir si cette espèce envahissante
vont migrer ailleurs au québec
la menace est bien réelle puisque le lac
brome se jette dans la rivière yamaska
etc les biologistes ont déjà commencé à
y trouver des écrevisses à taches rouges
la rivière yamaska s'écoule ensuite
jusqu'au salon et on peut imaginer
qu'elle ait clamé sa tache rouge
pourrait envahir la fleur et beaucoup de
courbes dont le bras des prochaines
décennies
le ministère a dépêché une équipe ou lac
brome les biologistes ont pris des
échantillons d'eau afin de procéder à un
test qui les aidera à détecter la
présence de l'écrevisse à taches rouges
dans d'autres cours d'eau ce qui est sûr
c'est qu'au lac brome
le mal est fait cette espèce
envahissante est là pour rester
l'expérience qu'ils ont été tentées
ailleurs dans le monde ont démontré que
l'effort nécessaire pour éradiquer une
population là doit être très intensif
dans un système que la gomme l'on parle
personne ne sait où s'arrêtera la
progression de lait cru et sa tache
rouge pour éviter la propagation des
espèces envahissantes québec a interdit
la pêche avec des appâts vivants en 2017
reste maintenant à voir si cette mesure
sera efficace ici maxime boire et radio
canada québec